what's the most money a company has
raised in a seed round that you invested
in three product okay great question
seed round pre product hmm I am very
much of the belief in investing in
companies right but after they launch
their product and I can play with it so
I think a company like superhuman
because Raul had done a company before
was able to raise a decent chunk of
change in their seed round it was you
know many millions of dollars but it
wasn't over ten and then looking at
let's see I I was in a later round of
medium but I think I've probably raised
a decent chunk of change
so cereal founders like a Mark Pincus or
Elon with the boring company forget
about me being involved in them I'm not
in the boring company but I am a medium
but a late around they tend to raise 10
million for 10% that's what I see a lot
of the times and so it's an outrageous
valuation when compared to the average
and probably the founders are getting a
5 X 10 X premium on their previous
experience for good reason you know
they're gonna get the product to market
they've done it many times before yeah
it's just interesting how 10 million
versus 250 million right it is just such
a wide gap it's huge and it's the
problem with raising that amount of
money I've seen it happen in later
stages is the whole team gets off their
game entitlement goes off the charts and
you have so much money
you basically drowned an opportunity it
would be the equivalent of like putting
a chef in a Costco or something you know
like a giant warehouse and saying turn
it into a restaurant and it's like ok
where do I even begin you know like
there's every single food item in here
it's just too much it's too overwhelming
to go that big that fast and you it
distances the core team from reality so
much and reality is the customer that
they start arguing over things like
chairs
or the receptionist's desk or where the
office is located or what the laptops
are and you know how many gigs of RAM
they have whereas in a regular company
you're like holy [ __ ] we're almost out
of money whoo we better get this product
to market and you need to have
constraint to be a great artist actually
a better analogy than the chef would be
just imagine you gave an artist a canvas
the size of like a giant mural you know
how like the side of a building and you
just gave them you know giant you know
oil containers truck you know milk
trucks of paint and you're like go ahead
they're like a little bit of a big
canvas here you know what do I even get
started that's why I like constraint
makes great art Bob Dylan said like
they're like hey you know why did this
album come out why did you make the
album cycle I owed it to the record
label and people are like oh that's
completely disappointing as a dancer so
I gave my back was against the wall I
had to get it out I couldn't delay the
record label any more so I had to you
know get my term paper in and this Bob
Dole's case it was the album and it
feels like now the tools are available
where people can create products so
inexpensively and so quickly that they
can get something it may be not even
fully into the market but to hand you
that it's almost unexplainable unless
you're working on something that's a
really hard tech problem why they don't
why would you go raise money before that
right this is such a great insight pump
because I deal with founders all day
long who tell me if you give me $100,000
or $250,000 I can build this and then I
say you know that's great and I'm
flattered that you're contacting me I
have a long list of people who've
already created stuff and who have a
hundred or a thousand users who are
asking me for 250k at the same valuation
why would I pick you over them and like
well I have great potential make you're
telling me that they're showing me that
and and really that's what I think a lot
of young entrepreneurs don't understand
is the the the people would get funded
in today's market because of what you're
saying it's so cheap to build if you
want it's about clubhouse or if you
wanted to build a podcasting app or
whatever it is you could build it in a
weekend sweat equity to three people you
don't need all that money and
so you've basically signaled to the
market that you are a permission asker
you're somebody who needs permission or
validation in order to build whereas
other people there they're gonna make
their album they're gonna tell jokes if
they're a comedian they're gonna make a
short film if they're if you know
they're gonna write their screenplay
they don't need permission to do it
right and that's where founders get
tripped up a lot is that they asked for
you know they're looking for some
validation from an investor you know and
really they should look at the investor
as somewhere between a checkbook or ATM
and a coach or you know a close friend
who can give them candid feedback right
that's really what you're getting when
you're getting an angel or seed investor
somebody who can be candid with you with
advice maybe introduce you to people
just be a good friend and on the margins
a little bit of money to spend on
marketing or hiring that third developer
but you really want to be a developer
which is why Combinator says you have to
have a technologist on your team you
need to have a developer a designer
somebody who could actually build and if
you can't build well what's your goddamn
excuse like go on YouTube and type in
how to build a website how to write code
and people like oh you know that's
ridiculous it's not actually ridiculous
there's free code Campo org I had them
on the podcast we made a small
investment in lambda school there's
lambda school if you want to pay money
and you could do it on the comm right
you don't have to actually pay them
upfront you can pay it on contingency
with an I is a income sharing agreement
so I say is a it's like so much
interesting stuff out there you really
have no excuse